تداول رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي مقطع
فيديو مصور لسوداني في احد شوارع الخرطوم
وهو ياخذ قيلوله غير مكترث لاصوات القصف
واطلاق النار الفيديو اثار جدلا واسعا على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي بينما وجد التصرف
الرجل فايق ورايق وبين من راه عملا متهورا
فيما اشار اخرون الى ان الرجل مشرد ولا
مكان ياوي
[موسيقى]
اقتحم ثور هائج ارضيه ملعب خلال مباراه في
فرنسا بعدما هرب من بين يد مروضه الذي لم
يستطع السيطره عليه نتابع
[موسيقى]
شهد حفل تتويج الملكه تشارلز الثالث عددا
من الهفوات والمواقف فقد انتشر على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي مقطع فيديو لحصان يفقد
توازنه ويندفع نحو الجمهور دون ان يتمكن
خياله من السيطره عليه بسهوله
ومن المواقف التي حدثت ايضا في حفل
التتويج لحظه تعرضي جنديا بريطاني لحاله
اغماء اثناء اداء تحيه احتفاليه البندقيه
الملكيه مما اضطر رجال الجيش الى جره بعد
سقوطه بصوره مفاجئه
[موسيقى]
وبعد انتشار اللقطات لها على مواقع
التواصل خلال حضورها حفل تتويج الامير
تشارلز الثالث وهي تبحث عن مقعدها في
الكنيسه عادت الفنانه كاتي بيري وغردت
ممازحه جمهورها على تويتر لا تقلقوا
وجدتوا مقعده
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات